[Music]
can an ev save you money it's a good
question but kind of tricky to answer
see electric vehicle advocates have been
saying that evs can be five to six times
cheaper per mile than gas vehicles and
recently gas prices have been on a wild
ride and joe biden has said he wants to
lower the price of electric vehicles
saving another 80 a month that you're
not gonna have to pay at the pump
it's led to a lot of people researching
if an ev could be cheaper for them we've
seen people just in a frenzy almost
doing research on what green vehicles
are out there but trying to figure out
how an ev stacks up against a gas
vehicle isn't exactly straightforward
it's hard to get an apple samples
comparison so to help you folks out i've
pulled together a bunch of resources
that can help you figure out if an ev
could fit in your life and save you
money let's dive in
[Music]
okay let's start with range because
according to analysts it's one of the
top concerns that buyers have although
ranges are getting a lot better i think
people still have in the back of their
mind is what if i just want to get up
and drive to texas one day most people
aren't going to do that in reality if
you're in the u.s and you want to know
the range of your ev then look no
further than this the mumrone sticker
it's packed with info about your
potential new car and if you don't know
how to read it don't worry there's a
guide to understanding it on the epa's
website but what you really want to
focus on is up in the top left this
shows you the range of that ev on a full
charge and it tells you how highway or
city driving might affect that range but
all that information is kind of useless
unless you know what your driving habits
are and i mean what they really are not
what you want them to be we buy vehicles
based on that one camping trip we're
gonna go on in five years now personally
i think there are two figures you need
to consider the first is average daily
mileage as this will give you an idea of
how often you might need to charge for
me i do about 20 miles a day so that
means if i had a pure electric kia nero
i could probably make it the whole week
without having to plug in secondly it's
worth knowing what a longer distance
trip might look like as this will tell
you if you ever need to think about
charging on route now for me that's a
280 mile round trip to go and see my mum
and dad which means that i could
probably make it there without charging
but would need to plug in in order to
make it back home mileage tracking apps
like trip log and mile iq can give you
an idea of how many miles you're
currently driving and if the car you're
looking at doesn't quite cover you for
the range you want try checking out the
department of energy's ev rankings where
you can see which cars offer the most
range fortunately i can tell you this
the average us commute to work is 27
minutes long which means that even if
you drove the whole thing at 60 miles an
hour most modern evs should be able to
get you there and back on a single
charge speaking of charging best figure
out where you're going to plug your new
ev in the third highest reason why
people do not want to think about buying
an ev was that evs are a hassle and i
think charging times really figure into
that if you're lucky enough to have a
garage or a parking space on your
property then you can plug straight into
a standard outlet but be warned charging
through a household outlet is far slower
than through a dedicated ev charger if
you want faster charging you might want
to invest in something called a level 2
charger which will charge your vehicle
quicker but if you don't have a parking
space you're probably going to have to
find a public charger fortunately
websites like plug share can let you
figure out where your nearest public
charger might be and it can be used to
help you find charging points on longer
journeys too if there isn't one way you
need one well biden's trying to change
that we'll build a national network of
five hundred 000 electric vehicle
charging stations so if range and
charging haven't put you off buying an
ev could one save you money well it's no
secret that electric vehicles tend to be
more expensive to purchase than their
internal combustion engine counterparts
my colleague mike kolias has been
covering the ev market right now you
know so few of these models they're just
now coming out the car companies want to
sort of put all the bells and whistles
on there and so you know they're
naturally going to have more content on
than they would on just you know the
average gas powered version i mean the
average vehicle in the united states
like total across the market is about
forty six thousand dollars right now the
average price for a battery electric
vehicle in the united states is sixty
thousand dollars in the us there's some
federal and state incentives to try and
bring that cost down if you want to know
what incentives might apply to you then
check out the alternative fuels data
center which has a full list for the
most part people can expect 7 500 back
in a tax credit
there are states that are pretty
generous you can get another few
thousand so you know if you if you
bought in the right state i mean you get
as much as 10 000 or even more paid for
by the government even with those
incentives it's often still more
expensive to buy an electric vehicle
than it is to buy a comparable gas
vehicle but given that electricity is
cheaper than gasoline in some states
there is the potential to claw back that
price difference over time how long
depends on those gas prices and how far
you drive but even if range charging and
cost are all working in your favor
there's one big thing that's stopping
you from driving away with a new ev
today and that's availability i talked
to a
buyer down in texas he got on a waiting
list in may of 2021 he doesn't expect a
truck before the end of 2023 maybe even
spilling to 20.4 by the time these
things hit the market it's already a
long waiting list for them and that's
the problem if concerns about
fluctuating gas prices leads you to
purchase an ev today you're not actually
protecting yourself from today's gas
prices you're effectively taking a
gamble on what gas prices might be in
nine months to two years or whenever you
get to drive the thing so figuring out
if it could really save you money might
require a crystal ball
hey do you know why it's called a
monroney sticker it's named after a u.s
politician called mike monroney who
sponsored a 1958 act requiring retail
price and other information to be
displayed on all new cars so now you
know and if you want to know more don't
forget to subscribe see you soon